bonjour bonjour federica
oui une édition spéciale ça notre caddie
en ce mardi tout à l'heure nous avions
déjà un premier invité mais là nous
avons avec nous en studio max est pire
bac à ce qui est pour quelques heures en
martinique ce qui explique que nous
fassions cet entretien comme ça
absolument ce matin bonjour bonjour déjà
je dis à mes compatriotes martiniquais
martiniquaise ombelles bonjour ça veut
dire déjà je suis très contente d'être
en martinique puisque c'est une île déjà
soeur voilà même si je suis là pour
quelques heures voilà donc on l'a
compris vous êtes une femme politique
guadeloupéen vous êtes députée
européenne vous avez été élu en 2019 sur
la liste du rassemblement national mais
vous avez quitté ce parti et sa leader
marine le pen à l'occasion de cette
campagne électorale qui se déroule pour
la présidentielle 2022 ce que d'aucuns
ont perçu comme une forme de trahison
rappelez nous pourquoi vous avez décidé
de rejoindre le candidat eric zemmour
max est pire bac s alors faut savoir
depuis un an ça n'allait pas les à des
gens et rennes par rapport au vote au
parlement européen je pense que les
martiniquais m'entendent aujourd'hui
qu'il ya eu un vote sur le l'article 12
contre le crime contre l'humanité et que
le rassemblement national a voté contre
j'ai été la seule à m'abstenir puisqu'à
l'époque il y avait des résolutions cité
c'était oui pour tous j'aurais voté pour
mais comme on avait cette résolution -
je me suis abstenu
malheureusement le rn a pris cette
position et moi je pouvais rien faire de
voter contre la reconnaissance de
l'esclavagé comme crime contre
l'humanité au niveau du parlement au
romarin du parlement européen les ja
après vous savez je suis guadeloupéen je
le deviens je suis inculte qui domine
c'est une femme de terrain une femme
qu'à ses racines a bien sûr et quand
j'ai fait
les élections européennes la ligne
politique que marine menaient ne
plaisait vraiment parce que je suis une
femme je suis pour bien sûr la priorité
localisme le marché de proximité
le circuit court avantage et notre
production locale pour nous martiniquais
nobel ou pain aliment eau et à l la
réunion et malheureusement depuis d'un
homme au parlement européen et le
rassemblement national sont en train de
fait des votes qui sont vraiment en
défaveur de nos compatriotes ultramarins
sachant que j'étais référente
responsables au niveau de tout ce qui
concerne les régions ultrapériphériques
en régie je suis aussi haut niveau au
parlement européen commission agri
puisque manger des compétences au niveau
de la paix tic agricole commune empêche
aussi et nous avons eu il n'ya pas
longtemps le 14 septembre jeudi twittait
pour pouvoir renforcer les rup région
ultra périphérique et le rassemblement
national comme d'habitude y se sont
abstenus - j'ai voté pour et à cette
époque au marine m'a appelé pour me dire
pourquoi j'ai voté j'ai dit non d'un
côté je suis pas une vitrine de service
je suis pas une carte postale je suis
une guadeloupéenne une ultra marines qui
défend les valeurs de ses compatriotes
j'ai été j'ai été pour pouvoir vraiment
défendre nos valeurs notre identité
notre culture notre patrimoine préservé
la culture que nous avons chez nous nos
traditions et aussi aussi on a eu aussi
un problème aussi sur les votes sur la
croissance verte et bleue qu'on avait un
rapport avec monsieur bigeon à l'époque
république en marche et monsieur rouge
et que j'ai entendu ce matin qui a parlé
qui en colonialisme je le dis qu'ils
voulaient dire un peu décidé moi je
n'aime pas qu'on décide moi je suis là
pour travailler pour les guadeloupéens
et les martiniquais les rayonner les
mahorais les guyanais tout simplement
vous allez nous dire justement lorsque
vous ce que vous proposez avec kery
james et pour ça et c'est pour ça j'ai
rejoint grille parce qu'avec ma demande
et max est viendra avec moi je vois que
tu es femme que tu n 15 il est ce que tu
peux venir avec moi pour faire le
programme outre-mer je vois que tu es
une femme dynamique et ce que j'ai entre
contraint eric un joli dhien c'est sa
capacité d'écouter d'entendre les gens
et c'est pas un politicien et c'est pas
un marchand de rêves alors on va aller
sur le fond parce que le temps passe
très vite max est pire bah casse parmi
les thèmes qui sont importants pour le
candidat que vous soutenez de désormais
donc eric zemmour il y a notamment la
lutte contre l'immigration alors comment
décliner vous ce thème vous pour les
antilles et quelles mesures préconisez
vous de ce point de vue alors déjà je
vais travailler je vais parler parce que
je connais bien sûr problématique des
migrations comme je dis déjà
l'immigration nous avons pas les mêmes
problématiques dans l'immigration dans
chaque département d'outre-mer nous
prenons mayotte c'est la pression comme
moyenne nous allons guyane c'est la
pression au niveau des scream à surinam
en guadeloupe en martinique bon on a
une partie jeudi il ya les haïtiens il
ya les dominicaines mais faut pas
confondre comme je dis parce que moi je
dis on a besoin les haïtiens quelques
freins par exemple en guadeloupe ou en
martinique pour la banane on a besoin de
main d'oeuvre il faut pas tout confondre
nous devons comme jeudi déjà parce que
pour ceux déjà contrôler l'immigration
mais comme je dis il faut contrôler
élimination et frontex ne fait pas le
travail déjà ça va être notre cheval de
bataille pour moi en tant que le tram a
rien à voir avec eric de contrôler cette
immigration massive
qui n'est pas contrôlé aujourd'hui par
contrex korité en guadeloupe et en
martinique en guadeloupe avec une
immigration massive eux non ça c'est la
guyane et à mayotte on va dire par
martinique c'est pas le vrai problème
que nous avons nous avons gagné
migration bien sûr on peut pas dire donc
ya pas de problème par rapport à
l'immigration s'ils nous pondent un peu
d'immigration mais je ne veux pas dire
quoi c'est une pression forte comme
mayotte et comme jeudi la guyane c'est
pas pareil mais nous avons nos problèmes
mais nous devons comme audi les gens qui
sont en situation irrégulière les mettre
en place j'allais toujours dit même si
j'ai tout rassemblement national pour la
guadeloupe et martinique mais les gens
aujourd'hui km en place ou les expulse
et non à les expulser s'il ya des gens
que ça fait 20 ans qu'ils sont là qui
travaillent on peut pas on peut pas dire
qu'on va les expulser les envoyer à
saint martin les envoyer chez paou non
faut régler cette situation mais
aujourd'hui nous devons contrôler
l'immigration en guadeloupe et en
martinique nous n'avons pas les mêmes
problèmes j'entends dire qu'il ya une
forte une version au niveau de la
martinique et en guadeloupe dominique et
haïtiens oui il y en a il y en a six à
ceux qui sont pas en règle faut les
faire rentrer chez eux mais ceux qui
sont là qui travaille depuis des années
je vois pas pourquoi on va les faire
rentrer chez eux je suis je suis quand
même quelqu'un d'humain parmi les autres
sujets souligné par eric zemmour il y a
l'insécurité vous avez fait allusion me
semble-t-il tout à l'heure la sécurité
des trafics de drogue et d'armes que
mettriez-vous en place pour lutter
contre ces maux
au niveau sécurité renforcés qui est
plus de police je pense qu'on doit
augmenter au niveau la police que ce
soit en guadeloupe en martinique même à
la réunion si j'étais à la réunion il ya
quinze jours régler ce problème de
d'armes illégales et c'est pour ça aussi
on doit arriver soit problème sécurité
un haut niveau bain et comment
prépare-t-on à beaucoup de moyens mais
en méthode magath méthodes et ben déjà
on m'a déjà en martinique comme je dis
on nous devons bien créer de l'emploi
plus haut niveau bas la gendarmerie les
policiers nationale
effective il faut renforcer des
effectifs il le faut il le faut
aujourd'hui on est en sous effectif que
ce soit en guadeloupe en martinique
je pense qu'il faut le faire mais pour
une police de proximité qui sera dit
social ou une police très répressive je
pense qu'il faut une police de proximité
déjà pour mettre la rigueur pour mettre
la rigueur parce que j'entends dire
qu'en guadeloupe c'est que ce qu'eric
zemmour on veut proposer une police de
protéger mais nous expliquez moi je suis
guadeloupéen faut pas mettre à
l'hexagone les mêmes problèmes que nous
avons en martinique aujourd'hui faut pas
connues et ont les mêmes problèmes que
nous avons à la réunion je point je
prends l'exemple de la réunion j'étais à
la réunion il ya beaucoup de violence
conjugale à la réunion en martinique
nous avons pas les mêmes problèmes
c'est pour ça nous avons fait un volet
nous avons sorti l'armement de wigan -
oui oui oui nous avons sorti un
programme national mais on sort lundi
prochain un programme spécifique sur les
douze territoires que j'ai eus vrai bien
sûr dessus par rapport à nos
problématiques que nous avons dans
chacun de nos territoires qui va sortir
à peu perdre en cinq exemplaires et je
vais vous donner un petit peu les axes
de priorité
le cheval de bataille c'est d'avoir de
l'eau potable dans nos robinet est ce
que vous vous rendez compte qu'on est en
2022 nous avons des réseaux vétustes
nous avons des réseaux qui sont ben on a
mis en toujours qu'ils sont pas qui sont
néfastes plus de 50 ans moi qui est
députée européenne par rapport à
l'article 168 c'est interdit aujourd'hui
qu'on n'est pas de l'eau potable au
robinet on voit à mayotte c'est le même
problème partout quant à leurs réseaux
d'assainissement n'en parlons pas on a
un gros problème les eaux usées vont
directement dans la mer et c'est pas bon
pour les poissons et c'est pas bon pour
la faune et la flore ça va être son
quinquennat de pouvoir qu'on ait de
l'eau potable dans nos robinets et
résoudre ce problème de réseau
d'assainissement
mais qui va être gérée par l'état
pourquoi je dis aujourd'hui je prends
l'exemple c'est pas possible aujourd'hui
de dire que ça se voit que les
collectivités qui vont pouvoir gérer il
faut que l'état soit dessus aujourd'hui
et ce sur ces cinq ans quand exeo moore
sera président de pouvoir régler ce
problème on a aussi ce problème le
développement sur l'estran 60 verte et
la croissance bleue pour moi aujourd'hui
c'est un cheval de bataille pour nous
développer lago transformation mettre en
avant l'art aux transformations nous
avons des formations qui sont pas
adaptés qui sont inadéquates pour nos
joues du pocono jeunes puissent rester
en un cynique il faut le faire
aujourd'hui ces formations elles sont où
et c'est pour ça que nos jeunes ipap et
l'avenir c'est nos jeunes martiniquais
nos jeunes guadeloupéens parce qu'il
parte il retourne plus et c'est créer de
l'emploi et s'étant pas c'est créer des
infrastructures créées d'activité créer
cette continuité territoriale est aussi
cette régionalisation merci m'accepte
pierre bakkas ont fait une pause c'est
bien ça
federica et puis ensuite on vous
retrouve et voilà durera peut-être des
questions d'auditeurs et d'auditrice ou
sinon moi j'en aurai une ou deux encore
un tsar opposé à tout à l'heure